bonjour umberto giovannini merci
beaucoup d'être en direct avec nous ce
matin dans la matinale d'air france
nouvelles restrictions donc qui entre en
vigueur ce matin en italie
obligation vaccinale pour les transports
pour tous les italiens
oui bonjour
effectivement la politique du
gouvernement italien fait des poufs et
les plus possible les non-vaccinés rck
kiné et pour le moment ça passe par des
réflexions ou hand et l'accès à la vie
commune on est effectivement les
transports commune faisait partie des
dix choix qui était dans le collimateur
pour limiter au maximum en la
résistance à se faire vacciner la grosse
question c'est est-ce y empêcher pas les
les mineurs des pas accéder aux
transports queen est pour le moment où
on se cette question n'en est resté
encore
ça concerne de quelle quelle tranche
d'âge cette obligation vaccinale en
italie est ce que c'est bien accepté par
par les italiens
alors ça qu'on ferme là je parle des
saisons est effectivement en dis donc
mais non on a vraiment pour l'arrivée
l'écart entre les vacciner les non
vaccinés malheureusement moi je trouve
qu'il ya un défaut de communication de
la part du gouvernement parce que c'est
pas parce que les vacanciers qui ont
fait monter dans le transport commune et
mettre son masque pas son nom a
correctement sur les nerfs ont pas le
maître du tout on s'est bien aperçu avec
la variable l'heure où il craint que ces
types des vaccins et même là je portais
un défaut de communication mme mbow je
vais pas rentrer dans ce vaste débat et
il faut rappeler aux gens qu'ils aient
fait de maxime n'empêche pas des plus
contagieux mais permet et d'éviter dé
développer des formes graves et du coup
des décrets problèmes suscités de
sanitaires tels des halles est saturé
lehrer doit encore après problème de la
rto effectivement
après est effectivement
dans les transports qu'une on sait qu'il
ya des proximités plutôt importante et
c'était plutôt surprenant auparavant
l'effet des mots des idées des
pacotilles augure figurer dans le
contrôle des traces pour coup maintenant
il faut comprendre aussi qu'est ce qui
va se passer d'avoir jusqu'à des
contrôles à roizard on veut pas empêcher
les gens de monter dans les transports
que lui ne s'y sont pas des pacs a tué
parce vaccinale par contre si l'on
contrôlait ils seront verbalisés et les
trouve que ferrovial et rappeler aux
gens qu'ils ont dit le dépasse il faut
faire toujours attention et j'espère y
est surtout de la période hivernale où
on sait qu'il a piqué d'épidémie aimant
et ya justement l'imposition d'un da du
port du masque est ce sp2 en plus dans
les transports en italie
alors pour le moins les rêves p2 est
obligatoire dans les cas des dix avions
et des trains pas pour le transport qu
il est obligatoire aussi dans les cas en
les personnes tentées on vient d'être
testée positive à cinématique et à ce
moment là on peut continuer à travailler
l'important les masques ffp2 après sur
ceux ci le gouvernement n'a qu'à venir
et les prix la cause est celle qu un
centime aux pharmacies mais aussi posé
là budgétaire et élima ce qu'il faut
faire attention parce qu'il marque mais
non on peut pas regarder pendant une
semaine sur ce il faudra être didactique
n'est pas d'apprendre par exemple que
les masques au bout des huit heures il
faut qu'il soit arrêté et on peut pas
tout le temps le maître la veille sur
vous et vous permet une fois mais pas m
couché ça qui est sa clope au bec mon
café la m
voyez donc ça au film il faudrait faire
plus d'éthique de la façon comment
n'importe quoi au moins ça peut protéger
le temps du transport le la vaccination
obligatoire je le répète dans les
transports est ce que ça pose un
problème pour pour ceux qui habitent
dans les îles nombreuses en italie
alors oui et surtout en plus d'un
répétitives il a posé des problèmes
parce que en
la bon c'est poids après des problèmes
constitutionnels parce qu'on disait dans
la cuisine les gens par action ils
pourraient plus sortir d'élan il met
effectivement voilà moi je suis pas
juriste donc je rentre pas dans cette
discussion moi je pense que comme j'ai
déjà dit dans notre président une
émission qui il a fallu prenons région
beaucoup plus
précoce déposé l'obligation vaccinale en
france carton en quel est l'état y
posent l'obligation vaccinale et
promoteurs je suis ni d'éventuels effets
secondaires destination je pense que ça
au départ c'était une fresnes a
alors à la vision plus importante des
gens pour la lgv action effectivement il
ya des gens qui ont des doutes et
aujourd'hui mon fer avec les actions de
formation on va le savoir tout sur tout
alors qu'effectivement les vaccins ne
rentrent agglomérat bhl c'est juste que
une thérapie qui permet de mieux gérer
les flux des patients d'accord mais
l'obligation sera permet de rassurer les
gens ouidah l'état
évalué le bénéfice risque on fait est
bon il ya des risques mais si des
risques qui vous allez avoir à les
prendre en charge alors qu'elle est
bénéfique sont évidents pour les
familles général donc vous auriez
préféré plus de d'information
justement sur ces potentiels effets
secondaires de la vaccination et on
oublie et en obligations et en
obligations gérer assure-t-on
obligations au moment où on avait décidé
de faire une campagne vaccinale plutôt
que cette chouette du pass tony
terre
d'abord des greens je suis pas qu'il ya
je pense que l'on réduit jusqu'à dire
voilà les mâles l'état fils qui est tout
le monde se vacciner parce que c'est
bien pour la couleur population et
malheureusement les pauvres personnes
qui rentrent de complications mais c'est
pas ça on le prenait en charge on le
vérifiera pas sous les cons je pense que
ça va s'arrêter le message plus simple
et plus clair merci beaucoup on a le
même débat on va le voir en france merci
beaucoup ouverte aux giovannini d'avoir
répondu à nos questions ce matin en
direct sur rt france